we'll keep taking calls the phone number
of course is 617 830 4750 will go to our
next caller from the 832 area code
what's your name and where you calling
from hi my name is linda and i'm calling
from houston texas great what's on your
mind um at the other day I read an
article in The New York Times saving
that suck Koch brothers and the group's
safe under getting antsy about not that
not getting the importance of the
Affordable Care Act not being repealed
yeah like they like paid their money and
they're not getting what they paid for
and they're concerned about all these
folks at these meetings you know at the
town hall meetings that maybe they'll
actually vote against a Republican right
so I don't know it just kind of got my
dander up is like we're not getting that
they bought and paid for in their upset
yeah I also was actually waiting about I
was also recently reading about the Koch
brothers targeting Millennials there's
an interesting article floating around
about that yeah I mean to some degree
Trump has already gone back on so many
campaign promises but if I had donated
to the campaign unless I was a low
information grifter as many trumpets are
and they're just going to go with
whatever Trump says I'd be wanting a
refund off of my donations because yeah
I wouldn't really be getting what it is
that Trump promise however however and
here's the thing Linda if you consider
the more the less well known donor so
everybody knows about the Koch brothers
but if you consider the less well-known
donors as Trump allows the lobbyists in
and is doing the you know trying to
strengthen coal which the world is
laughing at us for what Trump's trying
to do on coal so many of these other
issues they may actually be lobby loving
it because they're saying whatever Trump
said about the anti-establishment guy
he's coming back and he's going to
support business interest in the corrupt
and crony istic way that many
Republicans have and a lot of those
donors are probably loving what's going
on yeah oh yeah for sure for sure but
anyway love your show
alright thank you so much appreciate the
call multiple Texas car back today thank
you so much appreciate it